so you may be wondering what is actually
BPF and this is the the closest accurate
definition I could come to ebpf is a
programming language and runtime to
extend operating systems
that sounds very abstract
a more practical comparison is ebpf is
like JavaScript or Lua
but for kernel Developers
now maybe you're even more confused so
let's look at this
on the left we have JavaScript an
example of JavaScript how it's commonly
used right you use JavaScript to run
some code and some event happens for
example most common example when the
website user clicks on a button it and
submits a form
on the right side we have vbpf very very
similar but you run ebpf programs in the
kernel in the operating system when some
event happens for example when a system
call is being invoked when a network
packet is being processed when a file is
being accessed and so on so very
different layers operating system free
BPF JavaScript lure higher up in the
stack but conceptually they're actually
very similar they're making systems
programmable
why ebpf that's the second question I
usually get
operating systems in particular Linux
has become incredibly hard to change it
takes weeks or months to even get a
change upstream and then years for
consumers for users to consume these
Linux kernel versions these new versions
so the Innovation cycle is very very
very long very similar to hardware
this leads to this problem that's
similar to what we have for CPUs the
operating system is essentially using
building blocks because it has to
predict use cases it cannot adjust adopt
to changing requirements all the time
that's why the kernel the Linux kernel
typically has system subsystems that you
as a user can configure you cannot
program them for CPUs we have solved
these problems with higher level
programming languages like Java go rust
and so on
edpf is the same concept applied to
operating system so it gives us
programmability and thus allows us to
continuously adapt to changing
requirements and thus innovate very very
quickly that's the biggest fundamental
reason why ebpf exists
great so we have programmability how is
this different to things like Lua or
webassembly because there's lots of
other languages
much much more widely known ones that
have been around for ages that give
programmability
why and how is ebpf different ebpf is
specifically designed to be embedded
into the operating system Linux and
windows it can interface with the Linux
kernel so it can call into kernel apis
and it is restricted to run safely in
the kernel context
but it is aimed for kernel developers
and thus traditionally very hard to
learn and use Lua webassembly on the
other hand are designed to be embedded
into arbitrary applications or system
their general purpose and their aimed
application Developers
much easier to learn but they cannot run
in the context of your of the operating
system so the single unique feature of
ebpf is that it is embedded into the
operating system that's what makes our
ebpf unique we could for example have
chosen Lua as a runtime for the news
kernel and give that a name that would
be similar to what ebpf is today
how does ebpf work there is a language
and there is a runtime
the language can be expressed in a
variety of different languages sudo C
code is the the most common one where we
use a compiler like llvm or clang to
compile that into bytecode but there's
several different language Frameworks IR
libpf BCC to express ebpf programs in
different higher language higher level
languages all of this eventually produce
so-called ebpf bytecode that is our
program
then we have a runtime this is what's
embedded into the operating system the
runtime takes the bytecode verifies it
to make sure it is safe to run just in
time compiles it for efficiency and then
runs it at the requested hook points in
this example it is being run when system
calls are being invoked
so these three properties ebpf is secure
it has runtime verification it has a
Sandbox concept it has program signing
it is efficient because it is going
through a just in time compiler it is
embedded into the operating system and
it offers per CPU data structures and it
is port portable the byte code is
generic it gets just in time compiled
later on it has data type Discovery BTF
as well as a stable API how to interface
with the operating system
who controls evpf ebpf is controlled by
the ebpf foundation and the open source
communities around it if you are
interested in participating on the
governance side of ebpf foundation feel
free to go to ebpf.foundation
that's that's nice now we know what ebpf
is where is ebpf used today it doesn't
actually be a surprise it's incredibly
widely used we could look at the
psyllium users file it's everywhere but
that's kind of boring lots of logos
let's look at some more extreme use
cases
Cloud native landscape we see a couple
of projects using evpf but let's dive
deeper and look at like heavy
applications of ebpf that you probably
use every day
facebook slash meta is using ebpr for
load balancing it's called project
katron it's been used in production from
for for several years all ebpf Facebook
is using this exclusively for all load
balancing needs we have all three big
cloud providers AWS Azure Google Cloud
using sodium in their managed kubernetes
offerings many of you probably use a
managed kubernetes offering gke eks AKs
at some point they are using psyllium
and thus ebpf underneath
but even smartphones this is the evpf
page of the Android operating system
Android uses ebpf it has an ebpf loader
and it uses ebpf pro ebpf programs to do
traffic accounting it uses it to account
how much CPU memory each app uses and
can even do GPU memory accounting and so
on it's all done using eppf so when you
look at the traffic statistic of your
app how much traffic volume how much
Network volume it it consumed that was
counted using BPF
multi-cloud networking Enterprises there
was a fantastic presentation at ebpf
Summit a couple of weeks back where s p
Global presented how they're using ebpf
with sodium for a multi-cloud networking
layer to essentially redefine how they
think about networking the talk was
absolutely fantastic a road to invisible
Network smp's Global Network
transformation Journey you can go to
ebpf.io click on watch Summit recordings
and you will find a talk the talk
recording
but there is one more thing because the
biggest aspect of eppf where I think
we'll see a lot more Innovation going
forward is observability
so really happy to announce a absolutely
fantastic new uh partnership between
grafana and I surveillance grafana is
bringing their entire observability
knowledge and tools at Lockheed grafana
Tempo and so on and I surveillance is
bringing sodium tetragon Hubble for for
observability and our all of our ebpf
knowledge and together we're building a
new set of tools that you can use for
observability
a couple of examples Network
observability where you we can now embed
grafana dashboards directly into
psyllium's Hubble UI for amazing Network
observability metrics for traffic volume
Network policy drops traffic volume and
so on
but there is more we can also do ebpf
based HTTP tracing and HTTP
observability and for example build
golden signal dashboards that we see on
the right side of the screen as well as
integration in the final Tempo where we
can trace individual HTTP requests all
thanks to ebpf and those without
sidecars without proxies at all very
very fascinating and last but not least
because of because of tilium's tetragon
project we also have excellent
visibility into the security layer and
can for example display process ancestry
how how applications behave and what
commands they execute and visualize that
in in grafana tool sets as well as well
as things like TLS handshake monitoring
this was a five minute introduction to
to ebpf and um I tried to to use a
couple of real world examples as well
ebpf is already everywhere and we're
using it every day but there's lots of
more exciting things coming and I'm
looking forward to the to a whole day of
um presentations thanks a lot everybody